all right Jordan
hello Jordan uh where are you from
where'd you grow up grew up in Spokane
Washington born and raised there uh
lived there for 24 years now
and um I'm sure that's where I'll stay
you like Spokane yeah definitely it's
got its got its ups and downs but I
think for a city it's just right so
tell me about your your childhood
childhood was pretty good
um to start I my mom and dad they work
together
and I think it was that way probably
until I was
six or seven years old then they split
up I maintained a pretty good
relationship with both of them even
though they kind of didn't get along I
think that they realized they butted
heads but they didn't want it to really
affect how they raised me so
um I feel I had a good relationship with
both of them growing up and um
it was pretty normal you know good
school live right across the street from
my school
and uh yeah so
you graduated high school did not
graduate high school I got my GED and I
did an alternative program so
for me high school was just it was kind
of hard to um
show up on time at
seven in the morning or so so it was a
little tough
I never really had a problem you know
with the schoolwork or anything like
that it was just being there and being
on time so I think that was probably the
toughest part of school and probably the
reason I didn't graduate but I did get
the GED and
moved on with that
so you're 24 now yep a few years ago you
gotten you gotten some trouble though
yes back in 2020 yes
yeah so I guess the way to start that
would be
um
I was a drinker probably from the age of
16 until the age I mean even before that
I drank most of my life as even as a
child but it picked up and got serious
where I was drinking every weekend and
then
um daily around the age of 21 but from
probably 16 to 21 I was drinking heavily
and um back in April of 2020
my father had passed away and
with drinking being my only Outlet it
really just sent me into a downward
spiral of how I dealt with my emotions
because I really didn't deal with them
and um
so three months let's see April May June
July
so four months later and July of 2020
I was on
a bender probably
three or four days at least and that was
leaving work driving home going right to
the bar
passing out drunk waking up doing it all
again and then the weekend drank the
whole weekend
came home Saturday night Sunday morning
one night probably it was closing the
bar down so it had to be 1 32 A.M
and um
just it kind of came to a head
everything in my life you know with my
dad passing away
a lot of problems in the family with
just
family struggles with like you know
addiction and conflict and stuff like
that
it all came to a head one night and um
July 2020 I came home completely blacked
out drunk
uh I went in my room and I got I had a
Glock 26 that I always kept loaded just
for like
home protection and stuff like that I've
been an avid Outdoorsman really like
shooting and things like that
I went home got my glock 26 loaded the
sucker and within a matter of having it
it was probably a couple minutes I I
loaded it
and then I put it up into my mouth like
that
to the roof and um
I didn't even think I just I squeezed
the whole gun that's how I remember I
don't remember pulling the trigger I
remember squeezing the whole gun because
I was just freaking out like
I I was just I was freaking out so I
squeezed it the gun went off and um then
I had shot myself I had attempted
suicide
and it was a Glock nine millimeter with
a jacketed hollow point round uh Sig
Sauer plus P ammunition
you know I tried to buy the best stuff I
could for like defense or whatever and
uh
yeah so it was a pretty powerful round
and
it went inside the roof of my mouth into
my brain broke apart in there because it
was a hollow point
and it split my face open you can kind
of see there the lines and
uh where it kind of blew my nose apart
and um actually real quick this would be
a good time to
so I wear these invisaligners and
they're like braces but they're way more
comfy and this is the results of the
accident after about two years of uh
surgeries and you know repairs
so I got a big gap there there used to
be a hole there
they had to do a bone graft so they had
to put a appliance a metal appliance
that hung out of my mouth that I would
tighten it and it would push the bone
over
and over time it created a new space for
bone to be put in and grafted in the
hole in the roof of your mouth yeah so I
mean like you probably won't be able to
see it but
it's just a crack now so it's it's not
smooth it's not like the typical roof of
your mouth but uh there is room for an
implant that they plan to put in there
and your eyes are fine yeah eyes are
fine my eyes
um growing up I was diagnosed with
keratoconus which is like a cornea
disease so the way they explained it is
that my cornea is shaped like a like the
end of a football opposed to like a
basketball supposed to be nice and
circular
and it shaped it's all pointed so uh my
right eye is like
horrible Vision everything's blurry uh
the left eye is perfect 20 20 vision and
which is crazy because that's where most
of the damage was done from the bullet
so if I would have messed up my eye that
would have left me you know potentially
blind
and um
yeah that would have been no good so
going back to what happened with that
night like I said I was blacked out
drunk but the second I pulled the
trigger or squeezed on it two things
happened
one
I sobered up immediately like
immediately it was like I went from
being blacked out drunk to like I really
I knew what happened
and then number two was
excuse my language but what I had said
to myself was you [__] you actually
did it I remember saying that to myself
and another way that worked out was
I'll pop these back in
sorry so the way that worked was after I
had shot myself
um
I had I guess what they would call an
outer Out of Body Experience
um
it felt like I was glued to my ceiling
with my arms and my legs just sprawled
out and I was stuck with my back to my
ceiling looking down at myself so I
actually seen myself laying on the floor
and that's when I said to myself you
[__] you actually did it
because I don't think that my I knew I
was in a depressive place but I don't
think my true intention was to shoot
myself I think I was just so blacked out
drunk that's why I say I squeezed on the
gun I didn't really pull the trigger I
was just the anxiety the stress of it
all I squeezed and then it went off and
then instantly it was like you dip [__]
you actually did it
and from there it was no turning back
I was in a coma and um
that's a whole another story on its own
I mean
being in a coma I mean before my injury
I've heard people say it's kind of like
being in a video game and to be honestly
that's exactly what it was like for me
there was one point where I had
envisioned myself as
I was in a Mario Kart in downtown
Seattle I'm not from Seattle I'm from
Spokane
but for some reason I was in downtown
Seattle driving a Mario Kart around and
it was really weird that was one thing
that happened
and then you know that kind of makes it
sound all good and fun but then there
was a lot of stuff where like there was
this lingering sense of regret and like
something wrong had happened but I
didn't no I was in Mario kartland I
didn't know what the heck was wrong but
I knew something was wrong and that
feeling would not go away until I woke
up and they said you know why you're
here it's because you shot yourself and
I was like oh I still remember to this
day my exact reaction was just like that
was oh yeah because I've forgotten
everything up until they told me
what were you going through at this
moment when you decide to shoot yourself
I understand you were depressed and
drunk but
it was have you have you been like
yeah oh yeah I've struggled with anxiety
and depression most of my life and um
suicidal ideas yep for sure for sure I
was uh I used to be really like big into
self-harm I got scars you know cigarette
do you know if you might have borderline
personality disorder I've never been
diagnosed with it but I mean hell at
this point not much would surprise me so
um
I got scars on the arms it's real goofy
but one side was burns the other side
was cuts
and while everyone else was getting
tattoos my age coming up through high
school I was putting packs of cigarettes
out on myself to
and that's another thing that I
determined was like I was creating this
version of myself that it wasn't really
who I was it was um
like this hard mean guy that people
wouldn't want to interact with so I
would it was like a way to protect
myself if that makes any sense if I shut
you guys out first you don't have a
chance to shut me out so I just became
the worst scariest you know crappy
person you could imagine in high school
and even right out of high school
um it took a long time for me to shake
out of that I'm obviously not the same
person that I'm explaining right now
it's been three years since the accident
and seemed very positive and yeah it's a
lot of a lot of good has come out of it
I mean I had every opportunity to just
fold and let this all break me and uh
in more ways than one I mean
the way I told people getting out of the
hospital was like I had the golden
ticket for like pain pills they were
throwing oxycodones at me like crazy and
they help sometimes but I remember
telling my oral surgeon at one point
like I don't even I don't need these you
know what I mean like
they're just I'm not feeling the pain
all so many nerves in my face got
destroyed from The Gunshot that to be
honest with you I didn't have a lot of
pain through all this
you know I was recently in a car
accident actually where I um fractured a
rib that was way worse than
the injury with you know the gunshot
so I had to you know kind of tell them
like easy up with those uh pain meds
and that was
I caught myself with that one because
uh like I said earlier my family has
struggled with addiction before and you
know I have two with more than just
alcohol
and um
you know I grew up I used a lot of party
drugs you know smoking weed
um
I did get involved into using some pills
when I was younger
and they were oxycontins that's what I
was doing when I was younger so when
they started throwing these you know
pain pills at me I really had to I
realized that I was wanting to make a
change so I kind of was upfront with
them and said like you know I probably
don't need all these you know
so has your personality changed
drastically since before that shooting
yeah for sure
um I used to be really like just shut in
and introverted you would never catch me
like dressing up or like talking to
people and nowadays that's probably my
two favorite things to do is get all
good and dressed up and what in your
attitude has changed
I think mostly my Outlook in life and um
so even like for example on my really
really bad days where everything just
seems to be not working out I'm still
just grateful to be here because uh
I've seen the alternative and like being
in that coma with that feeling of regret
is like
my worst day alive is better than that
so
that's kind of what helped change my
outlook on life and become less
introverted
and wanting to be more helpful that's
another thing it's changed too is uh
how much helping people has mean to me
you know I started working in healthcare
after this
I started volunteering at a local church
of mine
a local homeless shelter telling my
story giving a testimony they call it
and um I remember the first time I did
one at uh Union Gospel Mission at the
homeless shelter in my city
I was I was really nervous because I
kind of just came in and freehand you
know freestyled it you know I didn't
prepare nothing just told my story
and a lot of these people were
um
you know they were homeless so and I
haven't dealt with a lot of you know
Street characters like that so at first
I was a little intimidated
and I'll never forget the first guy that
came up to me shook my hand and gave me
the tightest handshake and the tightest
hug I'd ever had from another human let
alone another random man
and he told me thank you for sharing my
story and um and it meant a lot to him
and that's when I realized like there's
something there that I it would be
selfish to try to keep to myself because
it was really painful at first I did try
to hide it you know
but like before The Gunshot I was really
introverted so so much so to the point
where after it happened none of my
family or friends wanted to even tell
anyone in fear of how I might react
because I was such a just a jerk
so it was Kept Secret for as long as it
pretty much could and then you know once
you come out with scars and you know
what top your head is shaved you can
only hide that for so long so that's
when I kind of determined that
you know there's no hiding it
it was a really bad situation but it
helped a lot in order to
um to change my Outlook and change my
life to the point where I wouldn't have
had any other way right now
your mom is here with us do you mind if
I bring her out and just I'd love to
hear her perspective on what happened
yeah for sure let's bring Jody out
all right so Jody you were with Jordan
when this happened
yeah I was home sleeping when it
happened
um
when he got home
he came in drunk which he's done before
and I had to work the next day so I was
just trying to calm him down like
because he was obviously irritated
something but it wasn't uncommon for a
night of partying
and so I asked him please try to keep
down I got to work in the morning and he
just was talking gibberish I couldn't
even really understand what he was
saying
and uh he kind of went on a little bit
and then he was sitting in my window
and he got up to leave and I was like oh
good he's gonna go to sleep
well he got to my doorway and
right when he got to the doorway he just
took a gun and put it in his mouth
and
and saw himself
you saw this happen yeah
I saw it happen he dropped to the floor
like a ragdoll like there was no life in
him I I mean literally didn't even look
like he had bones it was just like
hit the floor
and uh my oldest son was home down in
the basement I was yelling for him one
of us to please call 9-1-1 neither one
of us could dial the phone
it was it was a very very scary time
um
then
you know we finally did call 9-1-1 and
they've got there pretty quick
um yeah there we went back and were able
to read all the EMT statements and
I mean I think it was from the time we
called to the time that they had me in
the ambulance it was like under 10
minutes so I mean maybe nothing
spectacular but for just a random call
two in the morning you know it's not bad
so
but at first I knew he was dead because
he didn't move there's blood on my floor
and I saw him hit the floor like a rag
doll was his behavior
were there any indications that this
something like this could have happened
before it did
um I mean
with Jordan he's very private he doesn't
really share a lot
so not really
um I knew he was
depressed about his father passing
because it wasn't really expected
he was young
um
57 years old and died of a heart failure
kidney failure so I drinking's bad
now some people can do it I can't you
probably shouldn't either so
yeah
um
and that mixed with it his drinking is
you know
and one thing he didn't mention is when
he did do it
he instantly regretted it it was instant
regret
so yeah
okay how was Jordan's personality or his
behavior or his attitude changed since
since the accident well he found God
through all this
um he quit drinking
three plus years amen
um he's much more pleasant to be around
amen
these you know he's respects other
people he's he's a good kid I mean
is a lot a lot different he's
a better person he's lucky as well
how many times I've heard that I've had
doctors come in my room and say you're a
very lucky kid you're a very lucky man
and I'm just
laid there hopped up on whatever the
heck they got me on and uh like thanks I
mean
yeah I was I and I feel that and I truly
understand that now but it took a little
bit for that to set in that do you have
any more dark moments oh heck yeah I
mean I've I've never gotten to where I
was but I still deal with depression
anxiety it's just nowadays I've got a
better system in place than what I do
with it so when I start having like a
really bad day or a really bad week I'm
not gonna treat that by going out and
getting freaking hammered every night
you know if it gets bad enough I'm gonna
talk about it
um talk with my counselor talk with my
doctor you know I'm on medications now
that have helped me a lot
I was really apprehensive about those at
first too because I didn't want to be
like the guy that's on crazy pills or
anything but after they explained him to
me and kind of explained what they did I
was like okay there's a little just I'm
not getting enough of something in my
brain and this is going to help me get a
little more of that and
now so that made sense I'm taking I'm
more proactive now for sure and what I
do with um my depression and my anxiety
what are your plans for the rest of your
life
that's the million dollar question isn't
it I uh I got really big into Healthcare
and I became a nursing assistant and
that meant the world to me because for
one getting through the class I had this
goal that I didn't want anyone to know
that had brain damage or a brain injury
so how is your brain after the accident
is there any limitations uh my memory
isn't what it used to be and
um I've been recently diagnosed with
epilepsy and they think that
with all the scar tissue in my brain
that that's just not firing correctly so
they explained it as like a computer if
there's one wire in there that's messing
up the whole computer is going to be
kind of frazzled so essentially that's
what
happened and um I think it was back in
June of this year I was diagnosed with
epilepsy so I got on medication for that
and um
and the way we found out I had that was
actually quite interesting too
I got really involved in the gym and
working out and I was coming back from
the gym one day after work
and I was driving and I was like oh I
feel kind of weird and that was the last
thing I remember and um
I was going down this a River Road by my
house the speed limit's like 35 miles an
hour and that's typically if what I do
maybe five over so I was doing 35 Maybe
40.
and um thankfully no one else was
involved but I passed out had a seizure
while I was driving and smacked into a
tree and they think that once I had that
seizure I must disappeared the gas
because of the car was like bent in half
and the tree was fine but the car was
like
it was it was crazy so that's one heck
of a way to find out you got epilepsy
but that was another back to ER and
unconscious and breathing machines not
knowing what was going to happen so it
was the same Hospital same ER
same yeah outcome we don't know what's
gonna happen
yep same hot yeah that that hospital
that all that happened at was it's a
huge part of my life I almost died there
I went back to work there I went back
there after my car accident you know
it's just
that place will always be in my heart
working at it was incredibly hard and
the people who do work in healthcare
especially in a hospital setting are
very very very very very special people
and um it took a lot for me to admit
that
you know as much as I like healthcare
this might not be the best fit for me at
the moment because it was just so
stressful you know the hours I was
working 12-hour shifts five six days a
week sometimes and
I burnt out of that real quick and uh
ended up getting a couple of concussions
before I left the job that's what
Force kind of forced me out more or less
and nowadays I'm doing like in-home
healthcare
I got a couple people I take care of and
um
I'm kind of just want to see that
through for now
and uh
focus on
you know getting the epilepsy under
control because I don't want to oops
sorry I don't want to have another car
accident you know due to a seizure
so I can't drive right now for the next
six months of me being seizure free so
the accident happened in June I just had
a seizure
three weeks ago so that time re the six
months resets anytime you have a seizure
so now it's six months essentially from
you know a month ago
so somebody's telling you not to drive I
guess
yeah I guess so
yeah when his father passed he took it
upon himself
I wasn't with his dad when he passed he
was had been in another relationship but
he took it upon himself to pay for
everything and make all the decisions so
he sold his car
and
they paid for the whole thing and made
all the decisions not to be a Debbie
Downer but hell I didn't have a choice I
mean no one was financially prepared for
death you'll never be prepared for a
gift it'll never be there'll never be a
right time to die
but being so young and not realizing
like the financials behind it like you
grew up quick when you're 20 21 years
old and you got to Bear your dad you
know especially when half the family is
in like a conflict and nobody wants to
like take control of anything so as his
son that he was
pretty close with I felt that it was my
duty to make sure that you know he got
taken care of so
did my best in that whole situation and
Jordan what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in your
life from all of this
the most important lesson I've learned
is how you react to things
and how you view things
I don't think enough that we look at the
big picture of where we're in in our
lives I think too much we focus on
the situation we're in right now
and we might sometimes we never take a
step back to look at what's really going
on
and then you just you know the
negativity can stack up so
the biggest lesson I've learned is to
just
always be teachable stay you know do
your best to stay positive and look at
the big picture and things because
I mean it might be easier for me to say
this I don't know but the way I feel is
it's never truly as bad as you think it
is
um I mean yeah everything that we go
through is valid to us
for sure
but I just encourage everyone to take a
step back and and really look at the
situation you're in because um
I really don't think it's ever as bad as
you know you might think
so all right Jordan and Jody thank you
so much for sharing your story thank you
I'm glad you guys are doing well now
thank you thank you very much